that's how bill burr builds his entire
act us through analogy is Mike's taking
two dissimilar ideas and saying they're
similar which sets to the audience an
illogical equation what's up hot breath
averse if you're looking to learn how to
write jokes like Bill burr you have come
to the right place
this is hot breath podcast the show
where you learn comedy from the pros
i'm comedian joel buyer that is my dog
guinness and today our pro is jerry the
joke dr. Corley over three decades of
comedy writing experience for people
like Chris Rock Jay Leno Bill Hicks and
now he is here to break down how bill
burr writes his material enjoy
that's how bill burr builds his entire
act us through analogy is Mike's taking
two dissimilar ideas and saying they're
similar which sets to the audience an
illogical equation my girlfriend's like
a smartphone huh right they're asking
they're sitting there with tension now
saying solve that how is that true I'm
curious and we'll all you do is solve
for true and the secret is it's got to
be true force smartphone all by itself
or a pearl friend all by itself because
if you had it if it if the verbage that
you come up with as the tie-in doesn't
match a person or a girlfriend then it's
not gonna work it sounds forced it's
gonna be odd but if you say my ex like I
say my ex it builds more of an
antagonistic situation I said my ex is
like a smartphone at any given time I
can usually find her at at least one bar
mm-hm and that's what a coincidence
that's so true but that fits for a
person or a smartphone one bar being the
signal of course right so but that's
just by listing everything smartphone I
was gonna ask how do you find the
connection between the income group yes
so you take you basically take if I
decide to use smartphone
say if I want to use sometimes in this
case what I'm doing is I'm taking an
element and comparing it to my wife
rather than find traits about my wife
and then finding the element to relate
it to like if I my ex-wife was a alcohol
right so I said so I you I played on
that angle I said what else is alcoholic
what else is alcoholic kind of funny
cars funny cars are alcohol fueled so if
I say might want my ex-wife yeah my
ex-wife she's alcohol
she's like a funny car alcohol-fueled
now I have a quick joke there but I'm
working the other approach to it the
alternate approach finding what is she
like and then finding something to
relate her to this way I'm taking any
element and comparing it to my ex-wife
and then listing everything I can think
about using subcategories of people
places things words phrases cliches
events and and I'll write that down
people places things words phrases
cliches events every single time I do a
list to remind myself because when
you're so close to it you're going
through the list sometimes you just get
too heady and I'll go on into any
cliches here what do people say when
they say this what people are involved
in smart from dude can you hear me now
that guy you know and I'll just write
down everything I can about a smartphone
what else in smartphone in the minutia
the signal what about the signal the
bars hey what are some of the phrases
hey my phone's only have two bars bar as
bar as double entendre that's a bar
could be a drinking establishment fits
from my ex-wife mic so my ex-wife's like
a smartphone you know at any given time
I can usually find her in at least one
bar Oh same phrase fits for phone see
wow that's how that that's an you
kidding bill bar bill bird uses analogy
that's what he uses through his whole
thing once in a while does a cliche drop
in you know so it's a you know like this
thing about this girl he was dating
being aggressive
you know she's aggressive you know she's
like I want you to choke me I don't know
if I'm comfortable with this you know
what if I choke too hard you know what's
the pressure what's the PSI you know
what is I and I don't want to choke do
heart is then she's like I want you to
take me against my will I was like what
is this Fifty Shades of rape you know
and he does that joke of course
our brains are wired to create
expectations since we're children very
definite expectations yeah so think
about it we you don't have to rush to a
punch because the audience their brain
is already creating an expectation you
know we don't have to you
to do it it's so firm you go like so if
you say in your head 50 shades of that
was such a popular book and movie that
people are already creating the ending
so all you have to do switch the last
word and it fits the scenario of him
being uncomfortable because he's like to
force you you know you know it's like
take me against my will what is it fifty
Shades of rape and he gets a quick joke
there because he shattered an
expectation and plus it's familiar and
oh my god so funny how that fits into
this place right here and we didn't even
see it coming
yeah you have you you're going through
like a checklist of all this and you
have like nine
there's like nine elements there were
nine psychological laughter trigger okay
nine stimuli that the brain respond to
that triggers laughter okay surprise
embarrassment superiority release
configurational incongruity recognition
and Bivens and and coincidence did I get
all those that's about nine sometimes I
forget right so then there are 13 major
comedy structures and so the structures
pull the triggers okay so and not every
joke just has one some have multiple
once some have ones where you're like
well that's kind of this and this you
know this is compare and contrast and uh
this yeah it can be both just like
you'll have literary scholars arguing
over whether something really fulfills
the obligation of meeting complete irony
you know same thing you know if you you
don't have to it's art so and also you
have to remember as Picasso said you got
to know the rules before you can break
the bones
boom it's an art yes so don't get all
wrapped up and it's gotta be this way
you know but a lot of times you can
tweak and go oh if I do make it this way
that joke snaps right and that that's
what part of comedians trying to just
get away with attitude they're not
learning the rules first before they
break right they just see like bill
Burgess up there talking know he's
worked over half his life at this art
form you know and he says the first five
to seven years of my career I did one in
two liners because I had to know how to
write a joke yeah and that that's what I
did too when you know how to write a
joke when you're on on the move when
you're in the flow it's easier to see
the opportunities or recognize the
opportunities and the mechanics and the
structure to be able to spin something
and go oh I just put two ideas together
I'm gonna now list real quick and put it
up there's the here's a line you know
what he does I go he was like everybody
wants to bang a hot chick you know but
you know the the guy work at her home
Home Depot can't cuz he's not a
celebrity
besides chicks don't dig lumber right
that's what he says that's his joke and
it's like all he did was take something
from Home Depot every time I see the
name somebody says Home Depot I see a
pallet of two-by-fours and he says
lumber and boom that triggers that image
and it makes us laugh what a coincidence
thank you for watching hop brethren and
sister Anne if you found this video
helpful please subscribe to the channel
and check out Jerry's full interview
right next to my head